اعلنت الدنمارك حصولها على موافقه امريكيه
لارسال طائره مقاتله من طراز اف 16 الى
اوكرانيا بمجرد الانتهاء من تدريب الطياره
الاوكرانيين وقلب مسؤول امريكي ان وزير
الخارجيه ارسل خطابين لنظريه الدنماركي
والهولندي يؤكد فيهما دعم واشنطن الكامل
لنقل طائرات اف 16 لاوكرانيا واكد بلينكن
في خطابه ان موافقه واشنطن على ارسال
المقاتلات لاوكرانيا ستتيح الاستفاده
الكامله من قدراتها الجديده بمجرد اكتمال
تدريب اول مجموعه من الطيارين
في مايو ايار الماضي اعلناه بل اعلن تشكيل
ما يسمى تحالفات طائرات مهمته تزويد
اوكرانيا بمقاتلات اف 16
وتدريب الطيارين الاوكرانيين يضم التحالف
احدى عشره دوله تقوده هولندا والدنمارك
ويشمل المانيا وفرنسا وبريطانيا وبولندا
وبلجيكا والبرتغال تملكه هولندا حاليا 24
طائره اف 16 تعمل في اسطولها الجوي اضافه
الى ثمانيه عشره مقاتله خارج الخدمه يمكن
ارسالها الى طرف ثالث كاوكرانيا بولندا
وبلجيكا اعلنتا رسميا عزمهما ارسال طائرات
اف 16 الى اوكرانيا اما الدنمارك
وبريطانيا فتقومان بمهمه تدريب الطيارين
الاوكرانيين على استخدام هذه الطائرات
ووفقا لصحيفه الواشنطن بوست فان اول دفعه
من الطيارين الاوكرانيين تتكون من سته
طيار فقط اي ما يعادل نصف سرب الى جانب
طيارين اخرين في قائمه الاحتياط
ولن تنهي الدفعه الاولى من الطيارين
الاوكرانيين التدريب على مقاتله اف 16 قبل
الصيف المقبل
الجزيره ناصر الحسيني نرحب بك ناصر تفاصيل
اكثر حول هذه الموافقه الامريكيه واي دور
متوقع للولايات المتحده في هذا الايطار
بلغ الامريكي الان مرحله الاعتقاد حقيقه
ان الهجوم الكبير المضداد الاوكرانيه الذي
تم طالما تم الحديث عنه لم يعطي نتائج
العسكريه المتوخات لم يتمكن من صدها جامعه
الروسيه لم يتمكن من ايقاف الجنود روس من
مضاعفه الاقتحامات وبالتالي الضغط العسكري
على اوكرانيا ما زال مستمرا هناك في هذه
الانباء هذا الصباح من واشنطن حول طائرات
الاكس 16 نوع من خيبه الامل الامريكيه
والحلفاء ان القوات الاوكرانيه او ان
اوكرانيا لم تتمكن في نهايه المطاف من صد
الهجوم الروسي ولطالما نتذكر منذ الايام
الاولى لهذه الحرب الاوكرانيه الروسيه
لطالما تردد الرئيس بايدن والبيت الابيض
الامريكي في تزويد الاوكرانيين باي دفاع
جوي طائرات من طراز اف 16 وهي متقدمه
وقذره بالفعل على المواجهات القوات
الروسيه على الارض هذا الشعور هذا
الاعتقاد بدا الان يتبدد في واشنطن
وبالتالي تلك الرساله لوزن الخارجه لينكن
لنضرائه الاوروبيين في نيتو بان الولايات
المتحده اقتنعت في نهايه المطاف بان
اوكرانيا بحاجه عمليا وعسكريا لسلاح الجو
هي تحارب دون تغطيه جويه حقيقيه وبالتالي
اكتشف العسكريون الامريكيون انها نقطه ضعف
اساسيه في المواجهه مع روسيا وبالتالي هذا
التغير الامريكي الاستراتيجي العميق يجب
ان يقول سيغير مسار هذا الحرب بشكل او
باخر الوزير بلينك الان بعث برساله رسميه
من الولايات المتحده تؤكد لنظاره
الاوروبيين ان الولايات المتحده الان لا
تمانع حتى الان كانت تمانع في مضاعفه
الضغط هذه الحرب وكانت دائما تسعى لمحاوله
السيطره على تداعياتها لك الان يخلص
الامريكيون الى انه يجب بشكل او باخر دعم
القوات الجويه الاوكرانيه الضعيفه جدا على
مستوى السلاح الجوي وبالتالي هذه الرساله
ومنذ مايو الماضي حقيقه رئيس بايدن اعلن
بشكل يوم باخر اوضح في واشنطن انه بدا
يميل الان الى الاعتق انه يجب
اتباع خيار تزويد الاوكرانيين بسلاح الجو
متطور هذه المره طائرات الاف سته عشر لكن
عمليا على الارض الان
اوكرانيا بحاجه لهذه الطائرات طالما
طلبتها الان تحصل عليها لكن لن تحصل عليها
غدا او الاسبوع المقبل او بعد اسبوعين او
حتى الشهر المقبل لتغير عمليا وفعليا سير
المعارك هناك مساله تدريب الطيارين
والميكانيكيين وكل موظفي سلاح الجو الذي
يتم الان في عده دول اوروبيه هذا سيعطينا
بعض النتائج ابتلاء من الصيف المقبل امام
بوتين الان الذي يدرك هذا الواقع وهذه
المعضله العسكريه الاستراتيجيه لاعدائه
يدرك الان ان امامه سنه على الاقل قبل ان
يتمكن السلاح الجوي الاوكراني من ان يكون
حاضرا فعليا على ارض المعارك هل سيتم
التدريب بسرعه هل سيتم تكوين ما يكفي من
الطيارين الاوكرانيين ومن يدعمهم على من
الفرق الارضيه هذه كلها اسئله الان تدخل
هذه الحرب امام مستقبل المجهول ربما وقل
ربما لصالح القوات العسكريه الروسيه التي
لم تتحرك من خطوطها
والجنرات وكثير من الخبراء العسكريين
الامريكيين في جلستهم الخاصه ليس
الاعلانات الرسميه يعترفون ان هذه الحمله
او الهجوم الكبير المضاد من الاوكران لم
ينجح على ما يبدو ابتلي الان الولايات
المتحده والحلفاء يبحثون عن طرق وسائل
عسكريه اخرى لدعم الاوكرانيين كي يوقفوا
واشنطن باعتداء سافر على سياده اوكرانيا
شكرا جزيلا لكم الجزيره ناصر الحسين